dans la fin des vacances au soleil pour
le raisin avec les toutes premières
vendanges notamment pour les bordeaux
blancs du côté de pessac
le reportage de françois privat et de
marie pierre cassignard va nous
confirmer que la récolte s'annonce très
bonne en qualité et en quantité enfin
une bonne nouvelle
premières vendanges de l'année dans le
bordelais ce matin au château la
louvière et premier conseil du
propriétaire des lieux
ici on respecte le raisin ceux qui ne
sont pas assez mûrs à votre avis vos les
laisser sur les pianos et ramasseront
plus tard perdre qu ils seront cinq
hectares de vignes qui donneront en
principe vingt mille bouteilles d'un
grand cru de graves blanc qui
traditionnellement se vendanges très tôt
dans la saison la coupe et le transport
des grappes s'effectue avec minutie faut
savoir ce qu'en fait on peut blesser la
vigne il faut pas un coupé n'importe
quoi faux le doré c'est avec le doré le
pourri faut l'enlever de fait rire est
un ensoleillement exceptionnel durant
ces trois derniers mois ont permis
d'optimiser la récolte mais ici on reste
prudent il ya toujours une incertitude
c'est la hantise des vignerons cesser la
pluie en tout début de vendanges parce
que ça comme promet beaucoup la qualité
du raisin et ça risque d'amener la
préfecture il faut donc vendanger au
plus vite puisque quelques jours de beau
temps sont encore prévues sur la gironde
pour l'instant toutes les conditions
sont réunies pour un cru exceptionnel
la densité de chaumont est actuellement
voisine de 12 degrés d'alcool en
puissance commencé à vendanger 28 août
et obtenir un résultat pareil c'est
absolument exceptionnel je n'ai encore
jamais eu dans le bordelais cette année
la récolte de blanc s'annonce donc bien
mais les avis sont un peu plus partagée
pour le rouge que l'on ne devrait pas
commencer à vendanger avant le 18
septembre